[Musique]
l'idée c'est de vraiment faire le lien
or entre le consommateur et le
producteur on à petite échelle on a
effectivement deux fois par an un gros
marché fermier mais ça a marché fermier
nationale à l'idée c'est vraiment
d'associer finalement les producteurs
avec qui on a l'habitude de travailler
qui commercialise dans notre boutique de
l'enfant qui a trois ans jusqu'à jusqu'à
la personne du troisième âge
y a vraiment toutes les approches voilà
l'enfant il ya un espace d'animation
qu'on a baptisé tous en cuisine avec les
deux cuisiniers de la bergerie qui
pendant deux heures de 15 à 17 vont
concevoir imaginer une petite recette
d'un goûter avec les enfants donc voilà
c'est vraiment très adapté un enfant le
public adulte adulte pourra s'y
retrouver en faisant le tour du marché
ou en vendée en dégustant s'est tassé de
charcuterie fromage alors que les
personnes un peu plus âgés pourront
retrouver un ami patrice qui a une
collection d'objets agricoles
d'autrefois
[Musique]
en tout cas notre exploitation agricole
et en agriculture biologique
on a
la plupart des artisans qui sont là sont
de toute façon raisonnée mais mais
l'idée c'est d'aider c'est avant tout de
pouvoir expliquer le lien entre le
consommateur et le producteur sur une
base de confiance avec le projet
effectivement les produits les plus
impossibles